the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire update video well
my friends this is a very sad day for us
game of thrones fans who love house
stark
unfortunately earlier this week the
winterfell set where how stark was
located was set ablaze in what is being
called a controlled fire that's right
the stark's home we all know and love
has officially gone down in flames as of
right now no one knows exactly why this
was done but as always it has led to
some speculation as you can imagine some
fans are now wondering what this could
mean for the future of game of thrones
successor shows that may or may not
involve how stark or their home of
winterfell a lot of fans are wondering
will this be the end for how stark as we
know it does this mean we will never see
them in the show again well luckily for
house of the dragon the show has already
finished all of their filming now for
those of you who have been wondering and
asking me we should see how stark in the
new game of thrones series although they
will not have a major role like they did
in the original show for those of you
that don't know how stark will have some
involvement in the dance of dragons but
i would not expect to see members of
this house in every single episode house
of the dragon will mostly focus on
what's happening in and around king's
landing and the dragonstone area now i
do also want to say just because they
burned down this castle doesn't mean
winterfell will be gone forever i would
hope that when and if we do see house
stark again it should be in a castle
that looks very similar to the same
winterfell set we saw in game of thrones
as you all know winterfell is roughly 8
000 years old therefore this castle has
been around for a very long time in the
song of ice and fire universe now
although it has went through some
changes over the years i would expect
winterfell to look very similar as the
same castle we saw in game of thrones
however with that being said that
doesn't mean winterfell will actually
look the same in house of the dragon for
all we know they may go with a very
different look since this is a different
show but i am kind of hoping they don't
since we know house of the dragon has
only set roughly 170 years before the
main events in game of thrones we have
already seen an example of this with the
new iron throne if you saw the new house
of the dragon teaser trailer then you
know the iron throne does look slightly
different
now the seat itself almost looks exactly
the same however they did add a hell of
a lot more swords so they might do
something like this with the castles in
westeros as well
now for those of you wondering the
winterfell set they did burn was the one
that they used during the later episodes
of the show the winterfell set that you
see on fire was the one featured during
the long night battle when the night
king and his army attacked al stark so
this wasn't even the original winterfell
castle not only that but they could also
build another one again if they needed
to film a lot of scenes at this location
as sad as it might be to see this castle
set on fire it also doesn't mean how
stark will be left out of any of the
future game of thrones successor shows i
mean this is one of the most beloved
houses in all of a song of ice and fire
so it would be silly to leave them out
of any new show entirely unless it was
something said over an essos of course
let me know what all of you think about
them burning down the winterfell set let
me know what effect you think this will
have on any of the future shows if any
at all
as always i want to thank all of you for
stopping by and watching my video i hope
all of you have a great day i will see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you